the taliban's takeover of afghanistan
nearly a year ago has reshaped society
most of all for women new laws restrict
their movements education and dictate
what they can wear
many women protested against them early
on but a harsh crackdown has driven
local organizers underground our next
report looks at the price paid by women
who dared to demonstrate in public
a dangerous display of solidarity
katul fahood leads a march
calling for freedom for justice for
women to be able to work
that was before
now catholic must work behind closed
doors here she's covertly organizing a
protest action to mark the anniversary
of the taliban takeover
she says this is the only way to get
anything done
after our faces were recognized they now
know us our photos were released and we
gave interviews to the tv channels
the tv channels aired our interviews and
programs and now we are being chased and
this is a serious problem
she's paid a physical price for her
activism
here she displays bruises and cuts from
scuffles at protests
one time she says she fled her own home
when the taliban were about to arrest
her
and broke her leg jumping over the wall
to escape
she also says she suffered a miscarriage
during a demonstration
many who showed their faces at protests
last year were later detained
some are suspected to still be in prison
others who were released fled to
neighboring pakistan
the next woman requested not to have her
name mentioned
they treated us very badly
they insulted us and told us to give
away our organization and they asked us
which party we worked for and accused us
of working for the resistance front
and they took away our phones
for those who stayed behind afghanistan
has become an increasingly dangerous
place and that has taken its toll
we have spent a very difficult and
painful time
we have suffered more pain
psychologically and physically
i'm currently not doing well mentally
and my family members are also not doing
well mentally
meanwhile the protests continue
just not outdoors
these women have gathered to send a
message to the world
calling for education freedom and access
to work
the only safe place to do it is behind
these walls
and joining me now for more from colombo
is samira hamid the amnesty
international south asia campaigner
samira you're regularly in touch with
women in afghanistan who have been
forced to sit at home because of taliban
dictats do they feel it's safe to go out
and protest for their rights
thank you for having me uh
yes based on the uh
discussions and calls that i regularly
make to um
women and girls in afghanistan
not only the general ones because of my
work but also the female family members
the relatives that i have um it is quite
a
difficult situation right now for women
and girls in afghanistan especially if a
woman
would like to mobilize and uh they would
like to go out on the streets to
for example protest uh
in one hand the taliban have banned
protests
earlier a couple of months ago
in other hands the taliban of course
used violence and uh uh
where they
they did not allow the woman protesters
to continue protests and also what uh
what we have seen the pattern and also
what we have documented in our recent
report is that
a majority of women protesters were
identified disappeared they were
arrested tortured and even they were
threatened to death if they continue uh
so this is uh it's a it's quite a
dangerous
environment right now where uh women are
uh working um however they have not
given up what i am hearing especially
from the woman who are mobilizing and
who are part of the protests from the
past right and that's what we see in the
report that we play uh just before the
conversation with you but it's also
pretty clear that the taliban have
broken their promises on women's rights
the promises that they were making
during the doha round of talks for
instance do you see a situation where
the taliban will restore women's rights
i i don't
i don't think so
i would like to say that when the
taliban took over in august last year
uh you know some of the fancy promises
that they made especially through
international media and in their
meetings with international community
there was a shadow of hope that
i had but unfortunately
the one year of taliban and afghanistan
the way they have dismantled for example
ministry of women's affairs the way they
have
consistently uh they have introduced
different policies and decrease on uh
women's rights on how women should uh
you know live in afghanistan and also
the fact that they have failed to
address uh the issue of girls education
which is a very straightforward thing um
unfortunately does not give me any hope
anymore you know they made these
promises to the international community
and the international community seem to
sort of accept it do you think it is
incumbent upon the international
community to actually force the taliban
to respect the promises that the taliban
themselves made
handed person
uh international community uh plays a
massive role in
where afghanistan is today we
they accept it or they don't accept it
but they are part of the problem where
this crisis happened in afghanistan last
year and
accept
blank promises and statements
international community until now have
not hold the taliban accountable and i
think after giving it giving them a year
uh to actually prove themselves that
they do respect
human rights in general but particularly
women's rights this is time for
international community to take action
this is time for the international
community to use their leverage to hold
the taliban accountable just one final
question ms amity if you're a woman or a
girl in afghanistan today what is the
message that goes out to them what
should they be doing
uh i think they are brave and uh
the fact that they they are showing the
world and they are showing the taliban
that as one woman have changed that have
one woman
or not the same woman of of you know 96
is is something that they should
continue because that's where the
taliban should know and the word should
know that everyone woman will not give
up and will not be silent
samaritan we leave it there thank you so
much for joining us today
thank you